this is Jesse I want her to be our new
nanny
Jesse maybe a Disney show about a nanny
on the Upper West Side but that doesn't
mean the creator's didn't sneak in some
seriously adult jokes that you may never
have noticed until now we can't believe
that a Disney Channel show got away with
that some of the jokes are visual and
obvious while others lay hidden in the
scripts but after this he'll never watch
this TV show the same way again
we all loved how mrs. Chesterfield was
flirting with mr. Bertram and seemed to
have a crush on him merely because he
saved Susie's life we saw her constantly
smacking his bottom and we all remember
that iconic time she asked him she was
also known for her catchphrase when she
gets Bertram to do something with her so
it doesn't really surprise us when she
says something wild and over-the-top
in this episode mr. Bertram and Zuri
watch a marathon of their favorite show
in order to find out a secret in the
series finale but they end up falling
asleep so when mrs. Chesterfield walks
in on them and sees mr. Bertram snoring
she says to Jessie
Oh Bert he's so adorable he's all sleepy
bye I just want to squeeze his cheeks so
Jessie quickly responds please tell me
you mean his face yes mrs. Chesterfield
please tell us you mean his face when it
comes to scenes between this couple
everything just gets and appropriate in
this episode Jessie tries to impress her
friend and borrows a Tiffany diamond
tiara but while recording the video
Jessie accidentally drops the tiara into
mrs. Chesterfield's hot tub and she
refuses to return it so Jessie and Zuri
turned to Bertram and convinced him to
ask mrs. Chesterfield on a date to
distract her and then everything just
got out of hand even though the butler
wasn't comfortable
he played along so Jessie could keep her
job he said that she brought out the
animal in him dancing passionately with
her then he said and mrs. Chesterfield
pushed her buns against his lap saying
that she knows exactly how it feels so
when the day was over
Zuri said that she knows what mrs.
Chesterfield wanted for dessert
Bertram a la mode and grown-ups know
what it means to eat a man on a date
after finding a nest of eggs on the
terrace Jessie and Ravi discover the
vistor Kipling is really a girl and a
mom-to-be which makes Ravi realized that
he may have to work at becoming a better
grandparent to baby lizards
however when Ravi realizes he cannot
possibly take care of all 12 Jessie
persuades him to give them out for
adoption
after Ravi interviews many people he
does not approve because he wants to
find the lizards good parents until he
finally meets a woman named Cassandra
who mentions that her boss is going to
take them upstate to a loving home but
Jessie and Ravi were horrified when they
discovered that in reality Cassandra was
going to turn the lizards into
accessories so Jessie mr. Bertram and
the kids went to rescue the lizards from
her we love a good cause however while
they are catching the lizards mr.
Bertram gets bit by ten lizards so
Jessie says oh then mr. Bertram says 12
out that sure hurt we all know that
Debbie Ryan is a beautiful young woman
and it's no surprise that Luke would
fall in love with her he has made his
crush on Jessie clear since the first
episode and certainly couldn't take his
eye off of her in the same episode they
were rescuing the lizards when they
finally found them Jessie says feel like
I'm being watched so Luke says what do
you expect when you not bite you well
seems like Luke just won't stop staring
but we get why that boy seems young but
he clearly knows how to flirt in season
3 Jessie falls in love with a guy named
Brooks
after becoming a couple he proposes and
they become engaged but she later dumps
him and runs away on their wedding day
not long after Brooks emails Jessie from
Africa and she instantly feels guilty
for bailing on him she then disappears
which makes the kids think she went to
Africa to apologize to him so the kids
follow her to Africa convinced Jessie
wants to rekindle her relationship with
her ex-fiance and determined to stop her
only to find out that he's seen a new
girl named kami
so when Brooks introduces the kids to
his new girlfriend Luke thanks her for
making their 18 hour plane ride worth it
so kami says watch it I can do two
anything at five minutes and Luke
quickly responds so I've got five
minutes
well our childhood is officially ruined
but at least he was subtle good job Luke
we have to admit we have a dirty mind
and sometimes we just can't ignore it
for example in the episode bad fellas
emma has a huge crush on a bad boy named
Vincent but when Jesse meets the boy
with the bad reputation she thinks he is
a bad influence on Emma and does not
approve of her seeing him as she's
worried that Emma will get hurt like she
did years ago meanwhile Ravi and Luke
are impressed by Vincent and even helped
him impress Emma by setting up the
screening room for his evening with her
so as a reward he gave them some
bathroom passes so Ravi quickly points
out that these are passes for the girl's
bathroom then Vincent grins cheekily and
said you're welcome
not cool Vincent not cool seems like a
swell guy it's no secret that Luke is
madly in love with Jessie and that
doesn't keep him from misbehaving
because that's the reason she gives him
a lot of attention in this episode in
season 4 the kids were looking for
Jessie but couldn't find her anywhere so
Luke holds the phone looking like he was
going to call Jessie to see where she is
but Emma points out that she had already
tried calling so Luke says oh I'm not
calling her I'm checking the webcam I
set up in her bedroom
sneaky Luke that just sounds wrong why
do you think he had a webcam set up in
her room is it because he doesn't want
to miss her and he wants to see her all
the time we really hope that's the case
speaking of webcams this isn't the first
time Luke mentions filming Jessie
without her knowing
in this episode Jessie finally gets her
big break as a stunt double to
Australian actress
Shaylee Michaels Luke's dad got him
permission from the director to shoot
behind the scenes for his film class so
he decides to follow Jessie with the
camera but this time not in a creepy
without your knowledge kind of way as
Luke says so what was he doing before
then Jessie quickly pointed out it might
be less creepy if you weren't drooling
so much and even the other actress asked
him to film their faces instead what do
you think he was filming guess we all
know why he was drooling now
keep dreaming young boy you can only
look but you can't touch
well not that he hasn't tried though in
another episode
put his hand on Jessie's back and said
maybe after dinner Lisa and Jesse
stopped him before his hand touched her
bottom
forget freckles when Jesse thinks the
Zuri has lost interests in bunnies
sitting her class pet that she
volunteered to take care of Jesse steps
in only to lose the rabbit so she
replaces the bunny with another and
paints it to look like the original one
to try to keep it from Zuri
however Zuri knows her bunny way too
well not to notice so she confronts
Jesse and they start looking for it
until they hear mr. Bertram screaming as
Zuri's bunny attacks him he then guides
them to the dumbwaiter for them to find
multiple newborn bunnies so Suri asks so
Jessie says that conversation is above
my pay grade Zuri now has to wait for
her health class to know the answer but
don't rush young girl Jessie is known to
have tons of sneaky puns like that time
in the second episode when we heard Ravi
talking about vanity ash but some things
just sound so wrong when said in a
certain way for example in the first
episode in season four mr. Bertram was
sleeping and Jessie woke him up by
snatching a paper off his face so he
yells well it's not what you say it's
how you say it but it definitely was
funny we'll give him that but if you're
still not convinced you should check out
this one in the first episode when Emma
was disappointed that her parents were
too busy and couldn't make it to the
science fair and luckily she had Jessie
supporting her Jessie convinced her that
the distance will never keep them from
loving each other and that their bond is
too strong to be broken so she
encourages Emma going up there and kick
some asteroid as kids we might have
thought that an asteroid is something to
be found in space but we all know now
that is something we all have on earth
if you still haven't noticed most of the
jokes come from the king of comedy
himself Luke Ross so here is another
inappropriate joke
Luke is responsible for when Emma finds
out that Luke selectively chose to be
her new photography partner she's
annoyed that she's left with all the
work as Luke didn't have an idea what
the assignment is about so when she says
the
Simon is to take pictures of New York's
flora and fauna Luke responds those are
hot latin twins Luke is always funny but
it makes us think he clearly had more
than the photo shoot on his mind but
that wasn't the end of it in the same
scene
Jessie asks do you have an off switch
and Luke replies yep you want to try and
find it we all know with Luke means buy
an off switch and looks like it's
already on apparently seventh graders
are not as innocent as we think they are
Jessie was one of those TV shows that we
all loved and that our parents hated
that's because there were a lot of jokes
that only our father and mother really
understood when it comes to
inappropriate and new windows in shows
there's always going to be controversial
views Jessie seems like a heartwarming
kid show at first glance and yes it's
funny but did they cross the line for
Disney which of these jokes were the
most disturbing have you spotted others
that we forgot let us know in the
comment section below
unless I totally misunderstood that film
in health class there has to be a dude
lizard involved don't forget to like
this video subscribe and hit that
notification bell for more great videos
from us here at the things bye for now